welcome to this video playing love life
from France yeah my writing has dipped a
bit if you look this in if you watch
this in chronological or in upload order
and that's one game I didn't upload term
which seemed very fishy to me like a
cheating type of fishy not completely
sure but I felt better to upload this
stuff so I just scratched the recording
Adam at one point during the play and
and messaged the cheating detection or
wise you seem well I'm not like one
hundred percent sure there are cases
where I'm really 100% sure that it's
cheating this was not one of them but it
felt still felt so we had to me that I I
couldn't really am couldn't really use
this recording I came on 93 and this
coke on you know I wonder ever can take
here and play just clean be sick so I
can clamp it should be three that sets
of course okay but still let's just take
this Nigel g 636 I don't want that so
keep it simple this is just a good
position I had Queen a5 takes a two but
I don't trust this kind of this kind of
rebels grabbing power porn some the side
of the board um I'm wondering though
what about Queen a five shellac okay I
don't want to take the part I want to
play Bishop before or make him for fame
for fate canceling now Bishop here
that's not bad threatening to take now
twice and take deform how does he safety
for actually check guess you do he
doesn't he
save it at all yeah that's nice just get
the default point
yeah it's it was a bit strange to put
the bishop here blocking the only I just
wait just just wait for a moment should
i do that on it can take on d4 with the
Queen that's probably probably the
easier way to do it and now may be nice
to e7 and Knight to c6 yeah the only
small issue might be that you can enter
on c7 now this I must be aware of
probably just take it or not should I
just take it hmm the nights are not bad
at all and I'm a bit a bit afraid of
night h5 if it could be a bit bit tricky
but this is this is ok I can play even
g6 to prevent that the night attacking
of the g7 pawn not that this is so
terrible but that's the only purpose
that this night might have ok so g6 oh
it's got this check here maybe maybe
just play play against you five now
yeah just player
try to play it safe and sound night f5
would be okay this double point is no
issue yeah I've made I have made things
a bit more difficult than it was
actually necessary I am pretty sure
about that I probably should have taken
e2 just this probably was the simpler
the simpler way to play check check yeah
but this is this is very nice i can just
take everything off now or wait wait
wait there is the check on a form
there's the check on a form mmm King da
takes on CH and Bishop EA dat the end
that's not so nice I have I can play
Knight age six and kick it out okay I
didn't go for that at all okay
check I need oh I thought you needed to
go back this is almost a mating net b6
and that's right anyway King i will need
to prevent that that's a very cute very
cute type of mating net b6 check I mean
al threatening a six and then be six
check made now if he wants to prevent
that I will be five be 67 million made
so Bishop a4 is probably what he needs
to do then be six check King be five
King b7 threatens a six checkmate and
the bishop can retreat down there is no
made really I guess there is a mate I
don't suggest that you just don't see it
I'm I'm too stupid to see it
there's a for music Shack ok this is
this try to to avoid the checkmate i get
b 5 i get b 5 and stuff in there's
nothing better right time warning back
check now but probably not
check I need to to enter at some point
here to open up the position King no to
c5 you know the King important game he
cannot really go for that so be five
before
yeah what is easiest my dad with the
check even and tonight a 5-2 to push be
three be three anything before
b3 that was king this King tease c3 this
yeah well I will promote the beep on any
way I can I can do those safety moves
kinky five the special form prop better
not just promote here I cannot enter
with the King still a chat a promotion
of always forget 2222 can set this up
check check check check check white
forfeits on time sir it is me two times
that to select the Queen when Wade Wade
Huntley before I do anything here I need
to I really need to to to where is this
always promoted queen here it is well
okay yeah I really made my life a bit 72
tricky after this opening I think here
um this is already a chat a bit of a
problem he needs to play King everyone I
mean the only way to make this
displayable after Bishop before White is
basically losing challenge am I really
made it too tricky I should have taken
it to hear that's just easier to play
and not not that this is bad but it's
easier to take it to just to have a very
very simple piece distribution rights
against lights it's so it's easier to
win ya like like here just just take
this Kingda 7 rook c8 and trade
everything off it's it's just like
without the some sort of peace SME Trina
is absolutely nothing on that that can
be done for white let's say this a play
of six and get at the pawn here look
here looks knight c6 and it's it's just
easier to have the same types of autumn
of pieces and it just looks just bishops
them and it's easier to convert that but
okay this it was it was completely
winning so it's not like I should I can
criticize me too much about but here I
was surprised that he took I thought
that this is this should be objective in
tougher or actually g4 is a good move to
prevent this six
it's still a bit it's some work yet I
need to go here probably and I have this
space disadvantage you know it wasn't
necessary to go do to get there if i
just take this Bishop early and they
have I simply have an easier life after
that ok thanks for watching